hello everyone and welcome to the second
day of the finals of the opera euro
rapid this is game four
and magnus needs to win to tie the match
and force the match to go into tiebreak
so wesley won
uh the sec the the third game of the
match and uh
it's uh well it's all or nothing for
magnus wesley can just
enjoy a nice draw and he will still win
the event
so without further ado let's check it
out as this game uh features a lot a lot
of crazy ideas so
uh i'm sure you guys are gonna enjoy it
and yes magnus promoted to a knight in
the previous video that i've shown not
to a queen
uh but i don't know i i guess i was just
uh
i knew that the piece was immediately
captured so i presumed that
uh you know he promoted promoted to a
queen but it doesn't matter he could
have promoted to a
bishop a knight a queen or a rook
wesley's next move would have been the
same so
thank you for uh reminding me uh but
luckily it doesn't change the outcome of
the game
so that being said uh let's check out
this game and we're going to do all the
promotions correctly
so here magnus again opens with e4 and
another
e5 by wesley that knight to f3 knight to
c6 and now
bishop to c4 and wesley goes for knight
to f6
the two knights defenses on the board we
have d3 by magnus and now
bishop to c5 so kind of copying the game
they already played we have c3
and the both players castle uh we have
castles by black castles by white and
now d6 so very symmetrical stuff
rook to e1 again not interested in this
because of rookie 2 we will always
mention this
and now a5 as the white was threatening
some expansion here on the queen side
and here
now in the previous game that we've
shown knight b to d2 was the idea but
here we have the immediate bishop to g5
so
how do you handle this and how do you
get rid of this tension because the
bishop is in c5 it's not an e7
so you could have some problems here as
uh
well white might be interested in
opening up your king side completely
so here uh we have h6 forcing the bishop
to move back
bishop to h4 and now wesley even goes
for g5 so
attacking carlson's bishop here bishop
to g3
and now bishop back to b6 so it looks
very scary going for this expansion
uh but if it if it works why not we have
knight to
a3 by magnus and now there is a game in
the database where bishop to g4 was
played
but here we have knight the h7 by wesley
and it is
as of movie 11 that we have a completely
new game now wesley can start pushing
these pawns on the king side even
further
and he might even push g4 clear the g5
square for his knight and so on
uh so let's see what happened here we
have knight to c2 uh magnus wants to
remaneuver this knight into the game
also you have knight support for d4
if you ever want to push that we have h5
now threatening to win the bishop with
h4
so magnus has to make some room for his
bishop we have h3
and now h4 if you're wondering why not
the g4 to completely bust open the
position the problem is that
magnus has one move that doesn't allow
that and that move is
bishop to h4 going after the queen here
and after the queen moves now just
knight g5
and after the knight captures for
example captures uh you haven't really
done anything you've only weakened your
king and if you go for some further
captures looking for adventure
uh queen captures an h5 and it's game
over there's no move
black can make here now you cannot move
the f pawn this is of course
pinned and any silly move like let's say
queen g4
with an offer of a queen trait is met
with a with a
with a check made into a queen g6 check
you cannot capture because the
pawn is pinned and after the k moves
just bishop f7 checkmate
yeah bishop f6 checkmate so after this
h3 we have
the absolutely best move h4 pushing the
bishop back
and only now after bishop to h2 we have
g4 this is how wesley does it we have h
captures and now
bishop captures on g4 now carlson's
knight is pinned here and
wesley is bringing the knights to g5 to
help out with the attack on the knight
and the white's king side
will also be cracked open so here the
four magnus strikes in the center and in
doing so closes this diagonal
uh we have e capture sunday for knight
captures
the knight c capture captures on d4 we
have knight captures on d4 and
now c captures on d4 uh we have knights
to g5 now putting pressure on this
knight here
and magnus goes queen to d3 now he's of
course ready to move this knight but
obviously not interested in allowing
that
just goes knight captures on f3 we have
g captures
and bishop back to h uh 5 now not
the h3 you want to allow this
square for for the pawn and also the
queen might be interested in that square
so
i better not ruin your choices right
away and here magnus pushes
e5 and already we have a very very
interesting position
because wesley locks the position with
d5 if you capture then it's just game
over rook captures on e5
and that's it there are too many threats
here for uh
for uh for for white uh sorry for black
king is coming to h1 rook is coming to
g1 and it's not going to be able
the black king will not be able to
handle this if bishop g6 that we already
mentioned
that the f pawn is spin so just queen
captures and g6 ends the game
so instead after e5 we have d5 wesley
closes the position
bishop back to b3 and now a4 by wesley
and this is the position everyone's been
discussing uh white actually has a
winning maneuver here so feel free to
pause the video
and win this game for magnus while i
give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on
not being materialistic and ignoring
that bishop on b3 completely
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show the winning move here is
actually the incredible king to h1 you
have to free up this
g file for the rook as soon as possible
and now
uh the the problem is it's not uh
absolutely clear if you capture the
bishop then white is winning on the spot
because after rook the g1 check there's
not all that much black can do
because uh well you you could move the
king king to h8 for example
and then comes e6 but this e6 move is
the move that magnus
missed most likely i think he mentioned
it in the interview after the game
that he just completely crushes black
there's no defense
against anything here is just uh too
powerful of a move and for example if
you play something like
f6 to block off this uh bishop to e5
idea uh you have to play something like
f6 but then queen to f5 you go
after the bishop here and after let's
say queen e8 defending the bishop now
you go bishop to e5 and this is just
insane you're threatening to capture
here
and after bishop captures on e5 then
queen captures an e5 with
check and that's it king h7 queen
captures a queen g7 checkmate
so all of this is uh very very uh
interesting but
uh after this king the h1 move you don't
actually have to capture the bishop you
can play a lot of different stuff like
bishop to g6 you can just attack the
queen
but still rook the g1 you just spin the
bishop and you don't care
if king to h7 on pinning you even
sacrifice the exchange here
f f captures and now rook the g1
threatening captures and checkmate
and after let's say rook to f5 blocking
the queen's uh
reach of the g6 pawn now comes bishop to
c2 and you have this
very very nice position where white uh
has a beautiful position
most likely white is completely winning
but you know it's
not all that easy to take all of this
into consideration when the
the clock is ticking it's a rapid game
and you know your bishop was just under
attack it's normal to move your piece
when it's under attack
so magnus actually moves it to d2 you
don't want to play bishop to c to
bishop to c2 then black can just play
bishop to g6 and
trade a trade off those light square
bishops and
magnus wants to keep the light square
bishops on the board for the moment now
playing bishop to d1 is a bit dangerous
because it also
disconnects your rooks and once your
rooks have been connected you never want
to disconnect them that's kind of a rule
in chess
so here queen g5 check king the h1 now
hoping for rook to g1 to win the queen
but of course
just bishop to g6 now attacking
carlson's queen queen to e2 and
now even giving up the d4 uh pawn for
some attacking chances so bishop
captures on d4
and rook to g1 now attacking wesley's
queen queen to h5
and then up comes queen to d2 so
attacking the bishop here
and now of course you cannot capture if
you capture yes the queen defends it but
rook to g5 and hello
your bishop is gone so instead after
queen to d2 we have c5 defending the
bishop
and now f4 by magnus preparing uh
to further push this pawn to f5 also
this opens up an attack towards the
wesley's queen and uh if you play
something like
winter f5 then bishop the c2 could be
very strong so instead wesley plays
queen to h6 this is the absolute best
idea
because now f5 is impossible the queen
would be hanging on d2
so instead we have rook to g5 by magnus
now hoping to throw this
move in and the wasteland plays the only
move a good move he has and that's f6 so
challenging the rook here
e captures and now bishop captures again
with an attack on the rook we have queen
captures on the e5 by magnus
king the h8 and now it's a pretty pretty
tough position for magnus the
the rook is under attack the rook needs
to move but magnus doesn't move it
rather he plays bishop to f3 and this is
the correct idea you want to
give up the rook but wesley of course
doesn't want to capture it because if
you capture the rook
uh you're dead lost if captures attacks
the queen and after the queen moves
wherever it doesn't really matter it's
either this and then bishop to e5
winning the queen
or if queen to h7 again bishop delivers
check and then you have to
block with with the queen so it's the
same stuff so after bishop to f3 wesley
plays the absolute best move and that is
a3 he completely ignores
what carlson is doing and now just uh is
ready to capture here capturing is
impossible because the rook hangs on a1
so magnus quickly shifts the other rook
into the attack rook a to g1
and wesley just plays a captures on b2
again like in the previous video wesley
cool
as a cucumber so rook captures on g6
magnus has to go for this even though it
doesn't promise much but uh you know
uh it has to be done so here magnus goes
for it
rook captures queen captures rook
captures but now wesley gets his own
queen back into the game
uh b1 pawn uh delivers the check with
the queen
and now uh you have to move the rook
because the rook on g6 will also be
hanging
so rogue back to g1 attacking the queen
queen back to h7
and now magnus uh down uh down on
uh down a hole uh down sorry what is
magnus donald magnus is down the
exchange
uh but yeah he still has the bishop pair
and uh i mean
uh if he can get those uh bishops to be
fully operational will be very good for
him
so he starts with f5 and it's uh it
definitely makes sense he creates an
outpost here on g6 for the rook so
if the rook can come to g6 maybe bishop
to f4 and then let's say rook h6 you
could maybe trap the queen
but also it's just nice to have your
pieces so deep into your opponent's
position
wesley of course not interested in
allowing that he plays rook to g8
immediately tries to counter that rook
magnus goes rook to e1
and wesley immediately brings the other
rook into the game to counter now the
rook on the e
file so magnus now goes rook to e6 but
wesley very happily trades rook captures
on e6 and now
queen captures an e6 f we have f
captures on e6
by generating a past pawn here but
it doesn't help you because here just
queen to b1 check
and you have to block if block with the
bishop is just checkmate
the rook covers that square so you would
have to block with the bishop or the
queen
and if bishop d1 just rook g5 now
what do you do with the queen this is
covered you don't have any checks you
have to move and you also have to keep
an eye on the bishop and now after
something like queen f3
you still have to keep an eye on the
bishop rook to f5 now defended by the
queen and that's just it not much to be
done here queen e2 rook d5
and uh white is now completely lost
so uh instead after rook captures on e6
magnus plays queen captures on e6
and now comes queen to h6 by wesley
defending the bishop here
and magnus now has to figure out how to
get past uh
wesley's defenses because he absolutely
must win this in order to win the event
otherwise wesley is the winner
so he shifts the bishop over to d1 uh
maybe he can
create some chances here maybe bishop
here put some pressure here or maybe
uh you know the bishop c to to help out
with with the pawn but it's all very
unclear there is no good move here for
white so
magnus just has to wait uh for wesley to
maybe make some sort of a mistake
and he has to have some active moves
possible
so queen to g5 now threatening checkmate
and
just queen to e4 guarding against
checkmate we have queen to d2 attacking
the light square bishop and bishop back
to g4
we have queen back to g5 by wesley and
now f3
defending that bishop uh queen to c1
with check
king to g2 and now wesley doesn't even
want to mess around he just sacrifices
this pawn
to open up lines towards the white king
so king captures on h3
and now queen to h6 with check now with
the idea of queen to h4
so king g3 and now not going for this
right away but rather
rook to d8 first preparing to also
deliver the check with the rook on d2
after this check is given
and i know that we already uh said uh we
already declared
the worst the absolute worst bishop pair
in chess history
uh in the game from linares between
vastly manchuk and gary kasparov
but this could very well be the second
uh worst bishop pair in chess history so
i don't know i might even use this as a
thumbnail as it's uh
it's just amazing to have a bishop pair
this bad i mean
it it hurts seeing this uh but yeah what
are you gonna do
uh you know uh it can be helped uh so
here bishop the h3 was played
but now just rooked uh sorry queen to g5
with
check we have bishop back to g for
blocking now queen to h6
wesley is actually very happy with the
draw uh because he only needs a draw to
win the tournament so bishop uh
back to g1 and now queen to h4
with check king to g2 now comes rook to
d2 with
check and here the problem is magnus is
unable to escape
all the checks king f1 rook to d1 with
check you cannot uh do anything if you
go for king to e2 then the problem is uh
you don't
go for the bishop but rather queen to e1
is just checkmate so you can't even
afford to maybe
uh try and give up one of that uh one of
those bishops
to maybe stir some trouble because
you're just getting checkmated
so here came back to g2 by magnus and
wesley very happily repeats
rook d2 check king f1 rook d1 check king
g2 and after rook to d2 check
he was declared a draw as it's also a
draw by threefold repetition
so while the position is completely
winning for wesley wesley
doesn't care and he only needs a draw
here at uh
uh win the event as he already won the
won the third game and now
that's pretty pretty pretty bad as uh
as uh well it was it was a very good
chance for magnus he had the white
pieces and he could have uh
you know accomplished something but uh
you know it all came down to this moment
after wesley played a4
uh i mean but who will who will find the
move king h1 you play king h1 in this
position
i mean it's uh it's a uh really
you know a study like move and it's
still not clear even after the engine
gives you an
answer it's still you know there are all
of these possibilities over
all of these sidelines that you have to
consider and you know of course that's
uh a lot but that's the beauty of top
level chess
and as the wesley mentioned in an
interview after the game uh his favorite
format
of all the formats is rapid chess so uh
it's uh
definitely fitting for him to win this
event even though magnus is the world
rapid champion wesley again
uh takes the win away from magnus and
interestingly magnus still has yet
to win uh win a tournament uh in 2021
and uh he hasn't won a tournament since
he hit 30 years old
so that that must be very very depressed
depressing for him but
uh you know uh the the the year is still
long
so pretty pretty crazy stuff here and um
yeah wesley played the entire tournament
brilliantly he bounced back yesterday
which was uh
which was pretty pretty awesome uh just
you know
not going into into the second day being
being down a match and here
uh he just you know completely dominated
the the entire event sure magnus had
some chances but
exploiting these chances requires uh a
lot of calculation and a lot of
concentration which simply the rapid
time format doesn't allow but
that's the beauty of quicker time
formats we don't always get
the absolute perfect engine lines up to
move 25 even though sometimes we do
but we get uh you know crazy crazy games
like
these and this is what we we all want
uh and in the end what we all enjoy
uh so yeah uh that's the game hope you
guys enjoyed it
and my short coverage of this tournament
uh i would like to thank
marcus van atten phillip tuckman
michelle delmont xi jiang
and paulo tourini for contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
uh as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon
uh continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions and continuing the
morphe saga
and yeah that's pretty much it once
again huge congratulations to wesley so
on winning the entire thing
and that's it thank you all and i will
see you soon